so I was in this mood thinking about
this like [ __ ] [ __ ] where I was like
all cool like futuristic stuff and all
that and deep [ __ ] and like all you know
you know sci-fi deep [ __ ] but then I got
off the plane and my opener who sits all
the way in the back cuz he sits coach
[ __ ] cuz that's what he deserves you
know I make him do it and he was like
hey man I saw Jumanji and I was like ah
oh yeah he said yeah it's [ __ ] funny
that's a guy yeah he said yeah Kevin
Hartz funny and the rocks really good at
doing those movies I was just a great
he's a great movie star huh and I was
like yeah dude you know and I'm still
thinking I'm still in my [ __ ]
dystopian universe [ __ ] talking I think
about like you know robots and how we
can connect with you know how machines
will take over humans and this guy's up
here talking about how oh yeah it's cool
because the rock was you know they enter
this video game and the rock was like
this little bitch-ass and Kevin Hart was
like the strong one and then they had to
reverse roles and the girl was a guy and
Jack Black was a girl and now he's Jack
Black and this and that and he's into
and he kept all those big-ass rhinos and
I'm like hey dude you got to slow the
[ __ ] down you know when two people are
in two different moods and they just
don't meet and you just can't do it and
you're like and I was getting pissed off
for no reason but this guy's talking to
me about Jumanji for way too long during
the whole walk to baggage claim he's
talking to me about Jumanji and how good
it is now here's the other thing I might
watch Jumanji and I think Kevin Hart is
great and I think the rock is great I
love Jack Black and that other girl
looks like she's funny but like at this
moment in time I'm thinking about robots
taking over the world and this guy's
trying to talk to me about how good
Jumanji was and I'm like and I'm like
bro you got to stop I said you got to
stop talking about Jumanji but then I
realized I've done that and it's just
about moods that don't they're like two
ships passing each other in the night
man
right like have you ever [ __ ] been in
a bad mood and then somebody who drank a
cup of coffee walked around you just
wanna punch him in the [ __ ] face but
then sometimes that's you
so I learned something as I do that you
just gonna let people have the moods
that they get in you know you just got a
[ __ ] chill let the people have the
moods that they get in and you got to
you got to kind of stick why cuz here's
the thing my opener does that [ __ ] to me
too like sometimes I'll be like man how
come I get so upset when this happens
and I'll be like I don't know bro chill
how long we have to talk about this I
don't want to [ __ ] fire him every
time I don't know it's like a wavelength
though I know I talk about this but I
was thinking about this too in comedy
like all these Instagram [ __ ] videos
or that the people cut together and make
and think are funny is like when your ex
walks in and your girl's got a bubble
butt and like all those stupidest [ __ ]
[ __ ] videos every single one that's
just zero funny
it's like [ __ ] it's so bad and then
they go slow-motion and it's always the
[ __ ] it'll cut to a thing and a
close-up of life and then it's like a
cup a bad bad bad I got the bad bad bad
and some girl would be shaking her butt
and then and it's so bad and everybody's
so like washed out and the eye lines are
all wrong you know but like those people
are doing what they see what they think
like here's the thing if you're funny
you're on a wavelength that funny people
are on right like here's a guy who's
really good at it uh what's that guy's
name I always forget his name on
Portlandia Fred Armisen that guy's just
funny he's on that wavelength some of my
buddies are that way Bryan Callen Andrew
Santino these guys are just on that
wavelength Bobby Lee they're just funny
they get it they're on that wavelength
now that transcends you can be funny
it's weird because like funny is like a
language but in a wavelength but you can
be funny to people who aren't on that
wavelength now some people want aren't
on that wavelength don't get it but some
people who aren't on that wavelength you
can break through that wavelength and
reach them and they think it's funny
because you're showing them what's funny
it's like it's like it's like it's like
it's like a chef brings out [ __ ]
clams and like I don't like clams is
like well
these I made him a certain way and like
okay and you taste me like ah I do like
it I didn't think I would but I do that
person showed you what it's like right
but since that happened since we can we
I say we like I'm on the wavelength
saqqaq but like since a funny person if
they're on that wavelength and they
break through to somebody who's not
funny and they think that that's funny
then they see what that is that person
who is not on that wavelength will be
like oh that's what's funny and so then
Instagram they have an Instagram and
they'll be like oh I'm gonna make funny
videos I'm gonna do all the things that
funny people do and then that will be
funny but that's not what's funny what's
funny is that wavelength that they are
not on and so these videos that come out
that are for the lowest common
denominator which is like when your girl
has a bubble butt and she gives you some
cash wink gun gun I got the bad bad back
I got the bad bad bad that is not on
that wavelength but it's for all the
other people not on that wavelength that
don't get that wavelength it's for
people that walk around in the funny you
in the universe that just aren't on that
wavelength that are literally like this
when it comes to humor I shed it that's
how they are though they might be a
great businessman or banker or a [ __ ]
great in fashion or whatever the [ __ ]
even creatively they could be a good
painter but when it comes to humor I
leaked out some [ __ ] a leaking out [ __ ]
that's how smart they are they're not on
that wavelength but the lowest common
denominator is the most they're the most
people so those videos on Instagram
become [ __ ] popular as [ __ ] and then
those people get 20 million followers
I'm coming up I want the world to know I
did a 30 sugar is leaking that's the
truth dude because they think they are
all those people not on that wave like
they think bill burr is funny they get
it they think they get it they think
some of them think he's four they think
that you know
uh the other guys I mentioned Bryan
Callen it's funny you see Andrew Santino
and these [ __ ] you know but they're
not on that wavelength they're tasting
the clams from the chef that prepared
them the way that they didn't think that
they'd like them and it turns out that
they like them and that's the realest
[ __ ] I ever said man that's the religion
it's the realest reliable rope